Oliver Queen has fine do that guys are
gonna watch the DC TV crisis on there's
a crisis coming crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover final trailer I wanted
to cover it but it also ended up being a
topper board video request from one of
our top patrons Pete dot limit if this
is a top reward to your video request
John should definitely be in this video
hold on one second sorry John Wow I know
you were busy
taking a poop in the bathroom I was able
to pull up your pants before we got you
down here look this is topper work to
your video requests and you wipe my butt
dude I work really fast
Oh God done enough flash John has not
seen 99.9% finally crossing them all
over you saw like most of season one a
black lightning yeah everything you saw
the first episode of the flash many
years ago flash I've cut some arrow over
your shoulder anywho I'm excited you
have to be in it though let's watch this
oh my god
damn straight
that welling yeah and that's Kevin
Conroy
[Music]
whoa I don't even know backlight it was
gonna be
[Music]
now we'll be fine IRA thought there'd be
like some stinger at the end you maybe
maybe they'll surprise us stinger
15-second teaser in a couple days /
season 5 is the latest one that's
available on Netflix I think and I'm
almost done with the one with cicada I'm
almost done with that season arrow is
the one I'm most up-to-date with I'm
only one episode behind and the show
ends no I love that show you failed this
city or a queen I don't even do it well
wants to hear your impression like do a
drunk history gist of the show recap it
for me so I can watch this crossover
I am super super super excited for this
crossover I was trying to pay close
attention to see if there was any
Brendan Roth in the costumers I've been
avoiding the trailers for this and I'm
only watch this is Pete Dom wanted me to
I didn't see any Brian Roth in here but
he's supposed to be dressed as Superman
as well the Superman from Superman
Returns and Nicolas Cage Tom Welling is
returning and Kevin Conroy finally
getting to be able to do a live-action
Batman and you got bat woman in here I
only haven't seen the bat woman show but
I then the last crossover I thought Ruby
Rose was fine
you didn't entice me enough to want to
watch her solo series I think amongst a
bigger ensemble and with the other
players I liked watching her participate
so all the super and of course arrow the
flash Supergirl
legends there's so many things happening
in here I feel like they're kind of
designing this crossover because this is
the biggest one they've ever done I
think it's great because arrow is the
thing that started off they call it the
arrow verse he kick-started all this
some argue it was Smallville no it was
arrow kicked off the craze in the way
that like Blair Witch did for
found-footage it took 10 years for
paranormal activity to really really
i garyun yeah so it's cool that do you
have Tom Welling coming back and I don't
know filled on the suit he doesn't seem
like the kind of lad who would but it
feels like it would be worth it if you
did I really hope we see Kevin Conroy in
a Batman suit oh yeah that would make
somebody fan it like like even if I
haven't seen these crossovers like that
is something I would tune in just for
that moment alone or in those moment
it's only a few episodes so I'm limiting
the amount of knowledge on obtaining on
that's like if there's like casting
announcements that come out that are
just unavoidable like Kevin Conroy I had
no idea Black Lightning was in this I
thought black lightning was not
associated with the arrowverse sometimes
it's referenced I'm not fully up to date
with Black Lightning I feel like and I
don't quote me on this but I feel like
once upon a time I heard them say that
if they did a major crossover that's
where they would do it and we get to the
final episode of this crossover and we
get that giant ass ensemble shot oh my
god so orgasmic you know the Avengers
team will play they did it I have a
feeling there's gonna be some surprises
up their sleeve in terms of other
appearances there ought to be usually
what they do is I have surprise
appearances not always but sometimes
they have a surprise appearance by
former cast members or former
reoccurring characters and they bring
them back through this these have
usually involve you know Infinite Earths
so there's parallel universes and
there's you know time-travel involved
there's a whole bunch of things is he
gonna spin the world back yeah but I
don't know if they'll have any new
characters that they'll see here Mark
Hamill is the trickster in the flash
series but I think it would be really
neat if somehow they managed to pull off
even if it's like 10 seconds of Joker's
yeah that would be so cool if they did
that they would solidify like the future
of their TV endeavors yeah movin cuz
they could do anything and everything in
these crossovers these crossovers are
always so cheesy that are corny they're
highly entertaining they're also very
thrilling usually there's one episode at
least in these crossovers that gets me
teary-eyed like even in the cheesiest
episodes I'll start crying about stuff
like this is a kind of CW corny
television that I absolutely adore and
take seriously knowing no cheesy
crossover look as cool as their like
Earth X or whatever that last one this
looks crazier they work in the way of
literally if they just show for like
five minutes
you think you want this that's the only
way appearances Easter eggs and all
these things you want all those fun
goodies Black Lightning nose up to give
him some school advice and their leaves
I'm gonna catch up on a whole bunch of
shows this week television again I'm
gonna have four screens in front of me
each playing a season it's his final
tree that's Brandon Roth on the
thumbnail for this is it an Easter is it
like on a once in a pause of the exact
right moment you know I really hope they
bring back is the james marsden
boyfriend from that movie yeah was a
carrot the reason why these can be kind
of cheesy too is because they're so
expositional cuz they know that not
everyone watches and other shows like I
don't watch Super Girl I often have to
get all seasons worth of updates within
episode and I think they also design it
in a way and I think especially for this
crossover they're designing it in a way
that even if you like completely fell
off the show cuz I'm hearing so many
people who are like I don't watch these
shows anymore but I'm gonna be watching
this event this is like a television
event there's so much glory to be had
from it I'm just gonna be fun and
exciting now yeah my baby is that in the
future they'll get one crossover that
takes literally every CW show on the
network yeah so like Archie shows up and
the Nancy Drew Z they got again Dean
Winchester Dean are there they would be
perfect to help out in the situation
like Castillo keeps having a comment
save Dean's ass from things alright guys
well crisis on Infinite Earths crossover
you're gonna be watching this which new
appearance or reprisal are you most
excited for leave a comment down below
I really hope Felicity Smoak returns for
this episode if she has to
and some people seem to really hate on
Felicity whoever helps your terms you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification I'll get
notified whenever got a video keep a
look at our community page of I decide
to cover this record reaction at least
for patreon because I know WBTV can be
really like I know this video a lot of
time love reaction but like there's WB
TV or CW ones that I've done that I've
tried putting up on YouTube directly and
they always get blocked they come to the
studio and they knock on the door I know
Hakkasan often complains about the
troubles with the Piton thank you so
much dude I didn't realize you watch
these shows maybe we talked about that
but dude I'm so happy that you asked for
us to cover this I know you didn't
really have that crazy of a Thanksgiving
but my man make sure this Christmas you
have a hell of a holiday season man you
gotta get yourself some gifts and buy
gifts I mean top reward to your videos
on patreon
I mean why stop at just one that's the
best you could do I mean Pete done you
know what you need you need some some
love from Greg and John so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go outside we're
gonna build you a snowman and then we're
gonna do a nude photo shoot on and
around it we're gonna make the snowman
look like you and you can imagine
yourself we're gonna put it in front of
a green screen so you can photoshop any
love lead destination that we can all be
cuddling at and then you can put that up
on your Facebook and show the world hey
Greg and John they love me maybe a
little too much people will force you to
stop your pledge so maybe don't do that
you know maybe just go with my original
idea of all those videos wanted to your
equality